my apologies if my desktop decides to
blank I'm not sure how to turn that
feature off so as probably most of you
know bitcoin is based on proofs of work
you have this general concept that in
blockchains generally you have some
scoring function for a history and if
someone is trying to determine which is
the correct history among competing ones
they just compare the weights and the
one with the greater weight wins or will
eventually be a head is a pretty
reliable assumption to make out of the
system and the way the incentives are
set up everyone just builds on top of
the one with the greatest weight and
that just kind of keeps working the the
problems with using proof of work are
number one it's just wasteful you have
warehouses full of computers literally
doing nothing whatsoever and and it's
also quite centralized you wind up with
a few people who acquire lots and lots
of custom pieces of hardware that mind
particularly well and have particularly
cheap access to electricity kind of
doing everything so it's supposed to be
a very decentralized protocol and in
practice it's not as decentralized as
its really supposed to be so it would be
nice to not have these problems and a
good thing to do is to use proofs of
space you make it so that instead of
mining you have farming the bottleneck
on how much weight you can add to the
chain has to do with how much storage
capacity or allocating to the thing and
there's an economic argument of why this
works well it's that people are spending
over a hundred billion dollars a year on
storage media and at any time about half
of that is actually utilized so if you
could hand out farming rewards that are
a small fraction of that but allow
essentially all of the unutilized
capacity there to be farmed with the
people who own it hardly
noticing the difference as far as their
performance was concerned then this
wouldn't create any extra incentives for
waste in the system and it would be
fairly decentralized because the storage
is actually decentralized among a large
number of parties who own it the basic
idea here is there's a lot of some cost
and a lot of replacement cost on all
this storage but you want to do clever
tricks to allow very low marginal cost
of utility of proving that you have it I
want to be clear I'm not talking about
useful storage here this is not data
that somebody's generating and asking
for back again later this is storing a
very particular kind of gibberish that's
only really useful for proofs of space
I'll get to later about why that other
thing is a bad idea so this all sounds
great the problem is you have this
feature that it doesn't really take any
energy to do your farming but this
creates a problem problems related to it
not costing anything to do your farming
the most basic one is a grinding attack
which is an attacker just tries
different histories that they have a
certain amount of storage capacity and
they're like well here's my honest
history but I'll just twiddle a bit come
up with another history and another one
another one and just keep doing lots of
these until they find one that's works
better than the others and move forward
with that and now we're back to what
bitcoin is doing this is like something
we don't want to have happen now bitcoin
fixes this by embracing it in Bitcoin a
grinding attack uses the normal
operation of the system so you don't
have so you don't have to worry about
grinding attacks which works but it is
not ideal and not what we're trying to
accomplish with our proofs of space here
because as soon as you embrace grinding
attacks it really is all about
spending more CPU and there's lots of
ways this can be done there are lots of
cryptographic primitives which can be
Malley ated in all kinds of ways for
valid the values another kind of attack
is a rewriting attack which is actually
sort of the easier one to explain why
it's a big deal so in a history
rewriting attack you might have
something where the system's been around
for like ten years and there's someone
who's like a twenty percent it has 20
percent of the capacity today but the
capacity has been going up very rapidly
over time so as of a year ago they had
like a thousand percent capacity and
because it doesn't actually cost them
anything to redo history they just make
a whole new history since Genesis
there's a completely new thing and their
history will have greater weight than
the honest one that the amount of it
will be more smeared out instead of
top-heavy but it will in fact score as
having greater weight and you can go
well it's just throwing some check
points here in there just assume that
you never go back more than a year or
something that tends to create a lot
more problems than it solves
ads in all kinds of other issues you
really really want to have the property
that someone can just join and figure
out what's going on rather than having
to check in periodically to know what's
actually happening this is actually the
the potential for doing this in Bitcoin
is actually a lot more than people think
it is if someone were to like rewrite
the last day's worth of history of
Bitcoin they'd be being a jerk but they
would be getting their mining rewards
for it that they would have mining
rewards no problem same as if they'd
mind off of the honest head so it's
actually I'll get to in a bit the
reasons why that isn't done so much but
it's alarming this could be done even in
Bitcoin
so I'll get up to it now the reason why
people can't or don't do this in Bitcoin
actually a lot of it is the upfront
capital allocation costs that in order
to rewrite history you need to at least
temporarily have a majority of capacity
which means you need the hardware to do
that which means you have to pay for the
hardware - to be able to pull off that
attack which is a lot of sunk cost up
front although that's not as bad as you
would think because if you buy that
hardware you have that hardware and you
can continue to use it or sell it to
other people it would be entirely
plausible that at some point like bid
main or something could just take all
their new generation of chips that are
in inventory and just attack the network
while they're sitting on that stuff
really I think the main reason it isn't
done is because nobody wants to
undermine the value of the currency that
they're mining and this would do
tremendous damage to that and also
bitcoin is a very cash and carry kind of
a thing there really is no leverage over
transactions that are being done over
the Bitcoin blockchain so the amount
that you can steal from people by your
transaction rewriting is actually very
low right now but that is likely to
change in the future is you get things
like lightning and more smart contracts
and stuff so it's a concern so I'm now
going to rant I these problems of a
grinding and rewriting history are
generally referred to as nothing at
stake that name is a bunch of propaganda
that name does not describe a problem it
describes a solution and by stating the
solution it is implying that that's the
only solution to that problem and the
solution it's suggesting is not a good
solution in particular the solution it's
implying is
you must have steak and you must solve
it by having a proof of steak system
which is not true on top of that so I'm
now going to talk about why proof of
steak sucks so first of all as soon as
you go to proof of steak you've really
fundamentally changed your threat model
bitcoin is this highly decentralized
database that anyone can join or leave
at any time
miners leave if everybody leaves the
system can just kind of keep going new
people can join in and take over and
nothing bad happens if you have a proof
of stake system that isn't true at all
but spoof of steak is a decentralized
centralized system instead of a
decentralized decentralized system so
you inherently have a lot of
centralization among the stakeholders
then you start getting just whole
categories of issues so you have this
problem about well what's the size of
your quorum and well there are two ways
you can go wrong with your quorum you
can make your quorum size be so big that
in practice you never get a quorum or
you can make your quorum size be to so
small that in practice people can just
override the history and in practice you
start reading numbers usually what winds
up happening these cross on the wrong
side instead of they're being arranged
where they're both satisfied there's
there's a range where neither are
satisfied and that's obviously not a
good thing and another thing implied by
nothing at stake is that you have to
have some kind of bonding and slashing
people have to put their stuff at risk
so that they'll be hurt by bad behavior
if they're doing it wrong hence they
nothing at stakes and you must stake
things so that you can get hurt
so now we have to decide how bonding
works we have to decide what the
punishments are this is not good because
if you create incentives for bonding and
participation now you have a problem
that people can abuse the benefits they
get from bonding and participation and
make it look like other people aren't
bonding and aren't participating so they
can claim all the rewards if you don't
make it
sentence for bonding and all you have is
slashing for your bonding now why on
earth is anyone going to bond this is a
horrible deal you run the risk that
someone else will make it look like you
did some bad behavior and get slashed
you can try and get around this by say
oh well we'll just make it so no one
ever does bad behavior which can get
that I'm slashed well that's another
problem because as soon as you have a
net split as soon as you have like
multiple versions where and someone
might form but there's no majority
deciding at this point someone is going
to have to take one for the team and do
something which is technically slashing
just to conform a quorum and why should
anybody do that and there you're just
hurting them to do it so that's not a
good thing either the system can just
get totally wedged if you're trying to
go that way and then on top of that even
after you've you've bonded and slashed
and everything and have few people who
are actually sort of kind of behaving
reasonably you're gonna need to Duque
agreement among the people who are
actually there which is a lot of traffic
back and forth and it really doesn't
work right and doesn't it always has
this like what's the last message has
weird side issues so the thing about
this all these things I've been saying
they're not specific attacks they're
like whole categories attacks their
whole types of things you have to be
worried about in a proof of stake system
and that's like staking bonding slashing
checkpoints and K agreements and when
you find yourself this far deep and the
whole it's like maybe this is not such a
hot idea
maybe maybe if this worked people would
have done it long before Bitcoin maybe
we wouldn't have needed proof of work if
if this whole approach really had
anything underneath it so I'm not a big
fan of this approach
all right so now it turns out there are
some not dumb ways of combating grinding
and rewriting attacks so if we can come
up with purely technical solutions then
that's great we have a technical problem
we find a technical solution the problem
goes away and we don't have to worry
about it anymore
so there are a couple of tricks that we
can do first thing is we can bring in
verifiable delay functions or aka proofs
of time and we can alternate between
proofs of space and time so a verifiable
delay function is this thing which takes
a challenge and a number of iterations
and it does a calculation based on that
challenge where the output is completely
canonical that it requires that number
of sequential operations to do but can
be quickly verified that's a bit of a
mouthful there I'll sort of kind of get
into why it needs all those features
it's a new and interesting mathematical
primitive but that will prove highly
useful here we can also in terms of much
more straightforward things we can split
the blockchain between the trunk and the
foliage the trunk contains as little
information as possible and is the
source of all challenges it's the thing
that determines who wins so the trunk
basically only includes proofs of space
proofs of time and the occasional rare
work difficulty reset because you can't
completely get rid of those but the
challenges come from the trunk and all
the transaction information is included
in the foliage in this thing that's kind
of shadowing the trunk and that's
absolutely critical because it's trivial
to maleate what transactions you include
that's the functionality of the systems
that you can maleate what transactions
you include because this is supposed to
be a secure distributed database so that
is a necessary thing to do you can also
make it so that the proofs of space
inherent to the way they work is there's
a public key that they will be attached
to and you have to go with that public
that proof of space works so all you can
really do if you win is go okay I'm
winning with this particular key and you
can make all of your primitives all your
mathematical primitives be canonical
that includes the proof of space the
verifiable debility functions and the
signatures must all have unique values
and not have things that even look
mostly right but aren't technically the
correct thing and that actually proves
to be a bit of a tall order in terms of
getting out of things like a lot of
signature schemes don't have unique
signatures in particular or most
definitely does not and it's required a
bunch of new mathematical work to make
appropriate proofs of space and
verifiable delay functions there were
talks at B pace about the latest and
greatest and both of those things that
we are currently working on and I have
high confidence are going to work just
fine I am NOT going to summarize how
those work here because that's a whole
other subject but just for this for
purposes of this talk just assume that
we have working proofs of space and
verifiable delay functions so yeah in
order to get all this to work now all we
need are new proof is proof of space
algorithm a verifiable delay function
and some method of combining them so
that's only three new mathematical
primitives necessary to get this whole
thing to work so this is the road map I
came up with and this talk is not about
the proofs of space in the verify your
bladed rhythms this talk is about how
you combine them all together and
there's actually no materials anywhere
explaining how to do that which is why
I'm giving this talk because I won't
have a link to send to people to explain
what on earth is going on here this will
be the subject of a paper in the future
so first we have to get clear on what
the requirements of our proofs of space
and time are so
at a high level we can kind of pretend
that the proofs of space are just
generating a whole lot of bingo cards
somewhere in the range between zero and
one each bingo card is a point on it
that's all tied to a public key which
you will use to cash in your rewards and
sign the foliage basically the
individual bingo cards must be
completely non malleable
you shouldn't there are two actually
three inherent trade-offs that people
can do with the whole thing they can
always grind on it by just regenerating
their entire plot every time a new
challenge comes in so you want to make
it so you they kind of have to really
regenerate the whole thing which might
take a fair amount of computation and
latency to do or they can do the honest
thing of just generate of just
generating it based on the amount of
space that they have and they might be
able to do something somewhere in the
middle between those and you want to
make it so the potential trade-offs as
much as possible resemble you must do
one or the other of these things there's
actually another trade-off you can do
which is someone can always grind by if
your space of potential proof space or
even verifiable a functions isn't all
that large someone could just try every
possible value and try validating it and
see if it worked
obviously that's exponential in time so
not really much of a concern but is a
theoretical thing that must be noted the
this actually proves to be kind of hard
to do the straightforward thing where
you just have the bingo cards is subject
to these really interesting helman
time-space attacks
there's the beyond Hellman paper which
is what I covered in my talk at be pace
which basically gets the problems under
control there's a little bit of subtlety
to actually implementing it in practice
which isn't published yet but that's not
a big deal anyway this is a problem
that's under control
the requirements for the verifiable
delay function are that it takes a
challenge and and a number of iterations
it's really important that it be very
dynamic about the number of iterations
that it take the minimum depth circuit
to solve it has to be linearly
proportional to the number of iterations
the constant factor doesn't matter it
just has to be linearly proportional
that is the thing that's going to be
important here because the whole thing
is subject to work difficulty factor
reset it must output a canonical
solution and a proof both of them must
be reasonably short and it has to be
possible to validate the solution based
on the proof fairly quickly and the
approach were probably going to be
taking is actually using snark proofs
snark sorry these magical things were in
principle you can prove anything with a
snark the problem is the snark takes
four to eight I don't know some number
of orders of magnitude longer time to
run then simple like repeated sha-256
hashing but if we're clever we can tweak
things to make a video where the snark
can keep pace and it has to be
infeasible to prove an invalid to make
an invalid proof even if the amount of
time it's going to take to the amount of
depth that's going to take to do that is
going to be about right because for the
particular thing we're doing the outputs
of the verifiable delay functions are
going to serve as challenges for the
next block so it's very important that
they be very very canonical this is the
reason why there's actually a paper from
euro crypt that's on that there's an e
print up of as of this morning which is
a quite cute construction it actually
got best paper Eirik ripped that one is
just based on secure hashes
unfortunately isn't quite canal
Goll enough even though it is a good
proof of time it just doesn't have these
really nice super conical outputs cuz
this thing really needs to throw the
kitchen sink at the whole thing anyway
alright so now we need to hook it all
together so the way we do this is we're
gonna have a block chain and each block
in the trunk is going to consist of two
things it's going to have a proof of
space and then after that it's going to
have a proof of time which validates the
proof of space which came before it the
way you find a proof of space is you
take the hash of the last proof of time
put it on a point between 0 and 1 and
whoever has the closest bingo card wins
the way you enforce that they win is you
find the distance between the position
of that bingo card and the position of
that challenge that gives you some
fraction some small amount you then
multiply that by the current work
difficulty factor and round up to the
next integer this gives you an integer
that tells you the number of iterations
that the proof of time necessary to the
validate the whole thing is going to
have to run on the challenge which is
the proof of space
technically it's going to be the hash of
the proof of space and everything before
it but you know so this does a really
good job of making it so you really
can't grind on the thing you can try
lots of stuff but you do have this thing
where the not as good things that you
try are going to take a longer time to
finish that they are going to inherently
be behind it's not obvious that that's
enough but it does make it so there's
really only one piece of discretion left
which for the farmers which is whether
or not they withhold a winning proof of
space they can use their best one or
their second or third or fourth best but
really this is the only leverage they
have that they can take one away but
they can't
but but they can't twiddle it too much
technically speaking some games can be
played with the timing on the work
difficulty factors because when you have
a work difficult do you reset this is
another thing that comes into play so
you probably want those to be fairly
quantized and bla bla bla bla bla bla
anyway the work difficulty resets are
absolutely central by the way to how
block chains work and there's this
central fact about the maximum setting
on work difficulty resets and why it's
greater than why it's for which it
appears to be Satoshi Nakamoto knew and
just didn't explain to anybody but there
is this not yet published result of
doing analysis explaining why that value
is for anyway so when you have this it's
not obvious that this is enough so there
are a few tricks that can be done one
trick that you can do is make it so that
when you have a winning block instead of
just using that block to make the next
challenge you sign the proof of space
with your public key and that is used as
the input for the vdf that's going to
come right after it the this requires
unique signatures in order to work
properly but it has this neat thing
where if there's someone who has a lot
more resources than you they can't tell
what the results are going to be of you
winning box because they don't know what
your signatures are going to look like
because they don't have your private key
and there is this Lemmo which has been
shown and this not yet published results
that if you do this trick then an
attacker is not able to slow you down if
they're introducing things into the
system they can speed you up they can
make your chain grow faster but they
can't make your chain growth slower and
this is a very simple trick to implement
and seems good for a number of reasons
so that's a trick to be done
we do at this point have really really
good resistance to rewriting attacks
this is fabulous so let's say that some
that attacker wants to do the rewriting
of history since Genesis attack that we
discussed before in principle they can
do this right there is ten years worth
of history they can redo all 10 years
worth of history only using 10 years
worth of vdf which isn't really that
much computational power as far as
electricity is concerned by the way when
you start thinking about vdf salat you
start getting really really irritated
that Cs types talk about time for
algorithms that is not that word does
not mean what you're using it for time
as people normally use it means depth
and time as people use it in CS means
total amount of computational power kind
of an important difference and it starts
being really annoying where whenever
things say time you have to start
substituting in like computational power
in your head and whenever you want to
say time you have to say depth but this
is for historical reasons back when
computers were totally not parallel
people thought these were the same thing
and they're not so the this attack is
now totally foiled though it doesn't
create much computation it doesn't cost
much computational power for an attacker
to do this but it uses up a lot of depth
it is going to cost take them 10 real
qual clock years to rewrite the last 10
years of history meanwhile the honest
chain is going to have gotten extended a
lot more than the amount that they
extended their new things since Genesis
and their attack was all for naught
so that is totally fixed we got rid of
that problem depth it's real circuit
depth like circuit complexity the depth
the the like how many circuits you have
to go through from the inputs to the
output of the whole thing
it depends on how parallelizable your
algorithms are that's kind of the whole
point here is we're trying to come up
with algorithms that are weird as far as
being either very power Eliza bowl or
very not parallelizable in some sense
proofs of space are extremely
parallelizable and extremely not
possible to do them sequentially and
verifiable it delay functions are the
exact opposite thing where you can do
them very well sequentially and can't
paralyze at all all right so we still
have the remaining grindin attack I
think you've been going through these
slides from rather rather quickly so
plenty of time for Q&A here the so like
I said an attacker always has the option
to withhold something right which
basically means that they can take their
own history if you have say an attacker
who's trying to attack the system
they're not cooperating on the main
chain at all they have some amount of
storage and they want to squeeze more
utility out of it so they are not a 51%
attacker they're something less than a
51% attacker but they want to be able to
overtake the main chain by grinding
essentially doing what little grinding
is available to them and so they do this
by just taking every single branch that
they can at every single point in
history instead of just taking their
best proof of space they take like the
top hundred the top million the top
whatever and they do this for every
single branch of the entire thing just
ad infinitum is it's going to be huge
exponential blow-up that's going to get
pretty unpleasant pretty fast but let's
just say for the sake of argument that
an attacker goes in head and does this I
it's there is this very counterintuitive
thing here I do not have a good
intuition for this at all
but it turns out when you analyze this
and then an actual formal analysis has
been done and also like empirical
simulation has been done it turns out
that even when attacker tries all
infinity of possible things on the space
that they have the amount of extra
utility they squeeze out of the space
that they have is a small constant
factor it's actually II I find this
really surprising my intuition is sort
of the exact opposite of this it really
intuitively it's like well if I am
behind you it doesn't matter how far
ahead or behind you I am if we're doing
a random walk of who gets ahead if we go
far enough ahead
I'm inevitably going to overtake you
eventually
so how come like doing infinity of these
on top of it doesn't catch up I don't
know actually Christophe who I'm doing
this work with he went around to the
combinatorial mathematicians in his
department and asked this at them all
this question not in the context of
blockchains but just describing it in
the abstract and asked them what they
thought and they all guessed wrong so
makes me feel not quite so bad for
having wrong intuitions on this one so
and huh just because they faith there is
an actual there is an actual proof here
this has been actually properly analyzed
so and actually that that factor of e
can be improved quite a bit because like
I said before in Bitcoin you just sort
of embraced the grinding you you just
have everything be grinding and here you
can do a little bit of that what you do
is for the honest chain you go well the
honest chain isn't gonna follow infinity
of things but we're gonna say for every
block height the honest chain is going
to take the first three blocks that it
can for that and so that's gonna squeeze
that difference down and it turns out
that works quite effectively if you go
for like three say then the attackers
advantage
is reduced from e 2.7 to 1.6 and they
actually have to go quite a bit higher
to really get much more out of it after
that and so there's going to be this
kind of social convention of just how
many the honest chain follows that's a
rather easy number to crank up and a
very hard number to crank down so the
plan is we're gonna start it at 3 which
is a reasonable number and increase it
if that proves to be necessary there's
another thing we might do which is
instead of just taking that Delta the
distant of the distance between the
bingo card and the challenge and using
it for beta and we might take it's like
square or its square root or something
the analysis of that is not done yet on
what the trade-offs are and what what
what the consequences of making those
changes are alright so that was my main
thing and I'll take questions in a
minute I want to rant a little bit here
because I haven't been doing enough of
that the people keep coming up to me and
asking about different kinds of proof of
this proof of that proof of the other
thing these tend to not be very good so
I'm going to cover what some of these
things are but I would like to just as a
benchmark compare them to a type of
proof which is actually scores
relatively well on the scale of these
things but is probably not a good idea
the specific thing I want to compare
them to is proofs of bigger dick so on
proofs of bigger dick someone has
trained a deep learning system on images
and will rate them will rate the quality
of dick pics that are posted to the
blockchain and better ones win now this
actually is doing fairly well right off
the
because if we compare it to proofs of
participation and proofs of importance
and proofs of more nodes
those aren't locally auditable you have
to have been sitting there following the
history the entire time and just sort of
kind of trusting people somewhat if you
go offline for a while and come back you
have no way of in any meaningful way
raiding the blockchain and proofs a
bigger dick
to its credit has a defined formula for
how you calculate these things so it's
already doing pretty well there the
other problem is most of these
supposedly useful proofs aren't really
that useful we don't need more big prime
numbers and stuff if you look at usage
numbers for like pornhub and stuff it
appears to be that there is some amount
of market for dick pics in the world so
it's actually kind of doing better than
most of the proposals on that one
the scoring functions and this is where
proofs of bigger dick really falls down
pretty much the same way almost
everything else does the scoring
functions don't correlate well with the
intended values if you are training
something almost any deep learning
system for evaluating images can be
fooled with things that don't even
vaguely look anything whatsoever like
the images that it's supposed to be
going for using our current technology
and the quality outputs of these do not
follow a nice exponential distribution
and the slightest in particular they
cluster a lot you can just flip a few
pixels and it still looks like a great
answer to something that said an awful
lot of these proofs of things that
people proposed have dynamically
supplied challenges so if someone wanted
to do something for general fetishes
someone might happen to have a
particularly good picture of I don't
know a three tinted from Mars and
so they yet query the network asking for
one and then they can claim their own
rewards for that one however actually
compared to proofs of useful storage of
archival storage the general fetishes
one is really doing a lot better because
at least you'd have to keep
found the picture of the three titted
from Mars were proofs of useful
storage you don't even have to do that
because you can just take a key and use
this in counter mode to just generate
completely fake data which everyone else
has to actually store the data to claim
the rewards later and you yourself don't
have to do that you just store the seed
and there's no way to detect it because
these are supposed to all be encrypted
files which just look like garbage
anyway so I'm not a big fan of most
other types of proof of XY and Z they're
kind of stupid all right that's my whole
presentation do people have any
questions yeah yeah yes oh yes yes at
some point you have to have created a
proof of space right so trivially if you
want this feature that people can join
and leave whenever they want to it has
to be possible that when a challenge
comes up someone who only has X space
can make it look like 10 x space by
generating proof of space on it checking
for the best thing they can rewriting it
with another one checking for the best
thing we had and doing this repeatedly
so you can't stop this attack but you
can make it unpleasant to do you really
want it to take high latency I'm not in
practice the latency on these things is
going to be quite large actually because
they're doing rewriting of large chunks
of disk so you can just kind of make it
so that the minimum size on these things
is big enough that the latency is kind
of high uh it does sort of wind up being
a parameter in practice you can always
make it is it's a soft form to increase
the minimum size of plots that are
necessary so that can just be increased
over time analysis
so the analysis that has been done so
far hasn't been particularly strong on
looking at the amount of CP it's really
looking worth the amount of
computational power rather than the
latency of creating of redoing plots
although I think empirically the latency
is going to be much more of a hurdle
than the computational requirements of
redoing them over and over again but
mostly the analysis is looking at the
trade-offs right so it's assuming you
can use an amount of computation equal
to the size or you can have that done
upfront and reuse it over and over again
and just do like one lookup every time a
challenge comes in and and you want it
to be that those are kind of your two
options and that there's nothing that
does a particularly good job of scoring
better than both of those in terms of
both space and time
although it would be nice to have some
better color on what the minimum latency
is for setting up a plot as well though
that hasn't really been analyzed or
optimized for it although in practice
when you're storing something like on a
hard drive it just takes a certain
amount of time to rewrite the entire
hard drive like they only write at a
certain rate it doesn't so the analysis
so far doesn't really talk about that
and a lot of what's going on is a lot of
sorting on disk so sorting isn't really
that inherently sequential but in
practice when you're storing on an
outside media because it's really huge
that's gonna see realize a lot of things
yes you point it out they want to make
sure problems with like Bitcoin isn't
drives it drives all this prudent and
horrible miss allocation of resources
and all sort of no wasted effort
computing things like large primes which
could be computing something useful even
gold mining we use gold make sure your
circuits it's not completely wasted but
what's to prevent people from you know
building new classes of storage that are
optimized for these sort of proofs of
space but completely useless for
everything I it's because the
requirements of the proof of space are
an almost perfect match for what you
actually use storage for normally it's
like bits are bits it just looks like
storage if you're talking about things
to compute
I don't know convolutions or something
and or sha-256 hashes then whenever you
talk about any specific operation custom
hardware can really really outperform a
general purpose CPU for any specific
computation you can name but when it
comes to storage mass storage media is
already very very well optimized for as
many bits as possible as cheaply as
possible with very very slow access
times and that's exactly what proofs of
space need it's like maybe tape drives
can do something right so you might have
some better trade-offs with those but
that winds up looking pretty dodgy
because you have to do these lookups and
tape drives are really slow at lookups
stable stable think they will be round
like storage which through the line the
necessity to store the complete interval
by some kind of custom consultation yes
so the beyond Hellman paper is all about
making that impossible
yeah for algorithmic reasons you can't
get away with that but DRAM would be
horrible for this because DRAM is way
way more expensive than mass storage
media yeah you know this thing where
mass storage media you can set a bit and
just leave it that way until the end of
time and it's not costing you more power
where memory is costing you power just
sitting there doing nothing that's much
much more expensive to generate
please let's talk some new kinds of
stories or somewhere between you know
we're on this continuum between hard
drugs and variances yeah I believe that
almost anything that is actually useful
for proofs of space because Christmas
based requirements of look up times or
so packs and is all about the amount of
space basically almost anything that's
useful proof or proof of space will also
be useful for just a normal storage and
will cause people to be buying it just
for normal storage so you're still going
to be tapping into the unutilized
resources and mass storage the people
have acquired just for doing mass
storage it's a it's a nice to have sure
but if someone if someone is okay with
swallowing the computational overhead of
redoing the space over and over again
which might by itself completely wipe
out the utility of doing it because you
know you have a block coming in every
five minutes if you are just staying
online do this once you get this factor
of thousands over a month right but if
you're okay with swallowing that
computation because you like did some
hardware to do it then then maybe you
could get away with it and it would be
nice to make it so that the proof of
space setup also had a fairly
significant sequential element to it and
the one which we have right now haven't
don't really do that but so handling
graphs have lots of nice features to
them they are very complicated and have
annoying constant factors in them and
they are missing one big feature which
is they are not canonical at all they're
very easy to maleate so that actually
yeah yes so I kind of have an inverse of
the of his question yeah so it could be
that this isn't a problem unless you
have high frequency stuff going on but
your your your premise at the very
beginning was 50% of the storage is not
being used yeah the reason people have
extra storage is because they're
creating a buffer for some kind of
unexpected you can demand so that they
can respond so what happens in in your
system yeah if a player all of a sudden
because they have the set up for some
other application yeah that other
application needs all that it's actually
a really fun thing you can do which is
you take your storage media and before
you start doing anything with it you put
a pot over it you get it set up for
farming priori and you then put your
real fill out system on top of it and
you can do really fun things here like
if it's a raid you can like crack open
the raid for the farming so it's not
actually being good at being redundant
on the farming because you don't care
about that but you have this garbage
under in it as far as the real file
system is concerned it just needs to
zero stuff out if it wants to zero stuff
out if it just allocates a file there's
gonna be garbage there right but you
rely on the fact that modern storage
file systems don't overwrite everything
when they first start up they only
overwrite stuff when they have to so you
have your farmer sitting there accessing
this in like read-only mode and whenever
a challenge comes in it just goes and
looks up the spot that it needs to go
look up to get its response and if that
area of the disk has been overridden
then oh well you miss out and you you
lose out on the farming rewards
potentially for that well presumably you
were getting utility out of using the
storage right you're getting this kind
of just extra gravy money out of the
farming of the media but there's like
multiple billions of dollars worth of
resources being put towards farming
handing out like possibly like hundreds
of millions of dollars
the rewards so whatever utility you have
of writing are actually useful data over
your storage is going to be getting you
more value than the farming but that you
were doing is just this gravy money on
it beforehand so you're okay with having
that happen
yes maybe it sort of depends what's
meant by bad disk drives
yeah well it's weird because if a hard
drive merely has a whole bunch of bad
blocks you can just know what the bad
blocks are not use them so I'm not sure
how many rejects places get there there
might be some utility here - taking
factory reject hard drives and using
them just for farming I don't know what
the economics of that are likely to be I
figure at least it's just kind of making
storage cheaper yes scarcity come water
the price is no good because then yeah a
lot of these mining operations now he's
gonna be telling me is that maybe the
same thing will happen of hard drives
what are the ideas for denies the ideas
for it to not happen to hard drives so
we actually ran some numbers and in the
you know and it's this very like
socialistic central planning way decided
what the future storage market is gonna
look like for what we're doing we
decided in this Lake horrible nightmare
scenario where the value of our
cryptocurrency winds up being equivalent
to m1 like it turns out m1 and gold or
about the same value it's about four
trillion dollars so we designed we've
run the numbers and we've set it up so
that if our if the value of our
cryptocurrency hits four trillion
dollars which
wouldn't be the end of the world for me
personally but if it hits four trillion
dollars the amount of rewards that are
going to be happening are only going to
be around 20 billion dollars a year and
since people spend like a hundred fifty
billion dollars a year and going up on
storage media that wouldn't totally
screw up that entire market is it's it's
tapping into what is already a very very
big and underutilized resource yes so if
we just simply assume that disk drives
go away and are replaced entirely by
flash there's one other economic
complement which is the limitation to
the number of read/write cycles the disk
drive there's my understanding is that
the operating limits on flash has gotten
better over time as far as how much
overwriting is necessary for plotting
something it's like we haven't decided
how many passes it's gonna be but it's
gonna be like two or three passes over
the hard drive it basically sorts on
disk a couple of times but it's not
obliterating the disk it's doing a
little bit of access to everything and
that stops and then it's just reading
that's doing is like very it's doing
like wanna be challenged yes yeah what
what happened to somebody with very
large resources Amazon or Google decides
to attack this problem I so so if
someone has close to a majority of the
thing if they have a very large fraction
of everything they can probably
up pretty badly the idea is that
you want to be using something that's
already decentralized out there that
empirically because there are rewards
for joining and there's already a wide
group of people who have these resources
to play that you won't have anyone who's
a majority player right out of the gate
and the amount of decentralization of
the system keeps it from ever really
getting attacked and by that metric
isn't really doing all that well Bitcoin
actually is fairly centralized if the
government of China wanted to
up they could totally give it going yeah
the storage appears to be much much more
decentralized in terms of the amount
that's out there although it's
interesting because the questions of how
decentralized is storage really and how
much unutilized storage capacity really
is out there and where is it on some
level we don't really know and the
easiest way to find out is run the
experiment of makeup proof of space base
cryptocurrency see where the farming
starts happening oh that's just a rule
when you when you generate a proof of
space part of how the proof of space
works as it does tell you the size of
the plot that generated it so it's it's
you can soft fork increasing the minimum
size so that there will be a size
upfront probably like a terabyte and
that it might be increased in the future
any more questions yes was that just us
I believe I believe that was yes yeah so
if you really would I mean it's sort of
if we hit that I would be personally buy
farther it just person on earth so I
would be crying all that way to the bank
in that situation they don't expect that
to happen
it was just a useful exercise to try and
make sure that our numbers worked over
like basically like what if our market
cap is anywhere in a range from a
hundred million to four trillion and
make sure that it works well across that
entire range and it turns out by setting
an appropriate schedule and stuff that
is totally and then that's a pretty big
range that's four and a half orders of
magnitude
yes because look they're coming at least
that transaction cost is really high
which means it it really kind of limits
its killer house to things that you
can't you know use Visa to pay for a lot
of people talk about a about
what Bitcoin does and does not need to
do so I have this roadmap for crypto
currencies which is not really different
from the Bitcoin core debts for crypto
currencies it's like well how do you
scale like well you can't do on chain
scaling like at all that's clearly not
going to happen on chain scaling is big
enough for what it needs to be which is
it needs to be big enough that trying to
screw everything up by making
transaction fees hits the roof is cross
cost-prohibitive as it appears to be
somebody learned recently when they
crammed up the price of fees that's
gonna cost you 10 million bucks a day
which is not very sustainable so in that
sense the size of the blockchain is big
enough right now as far as scaling in
the future goes as far as getting
scaling and making it so the
transactions go through quicker the
obvious step one is you start using
lightning at work you're basically
switching to net settlement which is you
know the way banks work and then once
lightning is up and running which is
happening then you start doing like the
federated channels so someone can have a
piece of a channel and have some kind of
security
I'm not happening so you can go to net
net settlement and start doing things so
you can have real custody arrangements
over that as well involving some things
that are sort of the covenants can in
principle do that it appears to be much
simpler things than covenants might be
able to get you a lot of that
functionality actually so you wind up
having this system where you have the
blockchain which is kind of like that
wire and then you have lightning which
is kind of like Swift and then you have
some layer below that which is kind of
like just bank accounts and that can
just scale up globally and you can set
up
confidence and stuff over that see a
real custody arrangements and that can
work and then you can just do banking it
can become this substitute for banking
which is both more secure and more
expedient and cheaper than visa is and
can kind of be visa at its own game
which doesn't in principle look that
hard to do because I mean you look at
the way payments are done and it's
comically can you take out your credit
card and you put it into a thing and
then it electronically generates a
record of this transaction that you made
in the way it communicates this record
to you is it prints it out on a piece of
paper if it hands to you in the scan and
elsewhere this is just stupid and
archaic and ridiculous just compared to
what you actually wants is we're just
getting this electronically and every
single one of these is just ludicrous
and there's no transparency over what
the custody Arrangements are and like
where things might just get retro
actively pulled out of your bank account
after the fact there's scam artists to
take advantage of people not knowing
that just because you deposited a check
and it's been a month that does not mean
that the money won't just disappear from
your account so banking is portable at
its core things that it's doing and
trying to replicate that trying to do
better by starting with cryptocurrency
seems kind of ridiculous because you're
hollowing yourself you're using this is
like you're optimizing for ridiculous
levels of decentralization and security
when obviously visa could just fix this
stuff by actually fixing it and that
would even be hard to do but they seem
to have no interest in actually fixing
it so we're gonna have to go through the
backdoor this ridiculous system and then
build all this functionality on top of
it to in the end hopefully beat me as a
like at its own game
sizing out all these is going to fix
this one when it gets so interesting for
them looking that
so there was a time when there was a
dominant communications company in the
United States it was called Western
Union Telegraph Company and they they
serve telex machines paper tape remember
paper tape and they were confronted with
60-odd dial-up modems and their solution
was to make a higher speed telex machine
yeah Western Union Telegraph Company
then announced some years later that
they were retreating to their core
business which is allowing you to go
into a drugstore and transfer money from
the United States to Mexico yeah and the
whole communications yeah and so if you
look at these kinds of historical events
you know the buggy with manufacturers
sell them to make the transition to
Western Union still exists to this day
people still use it to send cash from
one point to another the amount of time
it takes the amount of expenses that you
incur doing this lose to doing the same
thing using Bitcoin that's just
embarrassing from having a network which
yeah was the dominant Network in the
United States they went to having
nothing yeah and this little business it
is often the case that the entrenched
players just don't get the memo that
they need to upgrade their systems and
they just die yeah you get these things
that are just ridiculous like if you
look at smart transactions and go what
smart transactions are really useful
like if you're a bank what turns out
smart transactions should you start
using and there's this very short list
of smart transactions that aren't stupid
right like so you can do things like ERC
20 so great you can do a legal a nice
and securities and pretend that they're
not securities supposedly it's magic
pixie dust that makes the SEC not care
except it turns out they do but if
you look at smart transactions that
hurts stupid pretty much top of the list
as atomic swamps atomic swaps are
anything they actually recently got
improved so they don't even require
security images anymore as long as
you're using aggregated signatures so
atomic swaps are great because if you
have two different financial
institutions both of whom have very
lightly trusted auditable public
Ledger's of what they do not blockchain
is just information about their records
that support really really minimal smart
transactions it becomes possible to do
an atomic swap between different
institutions which makes it so that
escrow should cost like nothing you just
do in escrow because you trust the two
banks reasonably they're both big bang's
they're not untrusted and so you just do
escrow across the two of them in this
way and maybe there are auditors of
their Ledger's so you have to trust them
even less right now banks look at this
and go oh we kind of like charging 1% to
do an escrow because it's no work and
you make 1 percent of 10 million dollars
and there are no we don't want this to
happen at all we have no technology
moving Farida the slightest and they
don't do anything about it so that's why
we don't have atomic swaps that's why we
don't have banks making lightly trusted
auditable public Ledger's so that we can
get rid of our escrow fees because the
banks don't want it how long did it take
for the world to get from the first
introduction to yes it gets to be served
an existential question of what's about
four thousand years now so it wasn't
until the sixteenth hundreds with
British yeah although you did have you
did before that have all these things
that
backed by something that's not someone
was storing chips or something and you
sort of had a seal on it and you know
where there was there were essentially
swaps but and trusted swaps but yeah but
it was shaky and they kept blowing up
every time the Wizards somebody went to
war if somebody always went to war so
yeah they were not reliable people were
actually you know the acid test your
chance to put acid on ya the coin to see
so yeah yeah it's so so so I think we're
it's a very early stage yeah your crypto
currencies are very early stage
technology right now and there's
definitely a lot of insanity around
investments in them at the moment which
is feeling a fair number of just
outright scams but the technology is
really interesting yes and so I'm
working on improving the actual
technology I think it's great and I
ventually but I think we will need to
have a trusted digital currency I mean
it's just it's just a fundamental
requirement at the planet given how
we're so and what you're doing is great
I wish i yeah well one thing that's
happened in the space is that the
available materials to explain crypto
currencies to people have really
improved a lot over time it needs to be
there is a very small cabal of people
who really knew how anything works and
even they weren't super great at
explaining it they were willing to
answer my questions but those guys did
but over time more and more people have
understood it in their actual classes
now and there are textbooks and there
are available materials for explaining
what's going on it's unfortunate that
not more work is being really done on
the core stuff because everyone's all
excited about doing new icos
and it's not on actually building real
technology
[Applause]
you